- Like people don't like
pain that's why most
people don't have six packs.
- [French Accent] A few moments later.
- Anybody got a six pack out there?
(clapping)
- Show me, show me, show me.
- Six pack, let's see it.
- Let's go, let's go!
Pretty sexy out there.
Yeah!
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(light music)
- [Interviewer] You're a
well known entrepreneur
and savvy investor, was
there any apprehension
about entering the cannabis game?
- No.
- Does the cannabis game...
- And then put dot, dot,
dot, dot, dot, dot, dot
and the reason why it's
just a one word answer
is it's binary.
Either you want to be on
the right side of history
or you don't and I'm completely convinced
that me entering the space is going to
be viewed historically correct.
- [Interviewer] In your opinion,
what does the cannabis industry
need to do in order to thrive?
- You know I think it needs to go through
it's natural progression of
wild, wild west to corporate.
I think it's happening faster
than I would like to see it.
I think corporations
have been quick to absorb
this industry and I
think you're gonna have
a little bit of a gentrification conflict
but it doesn't need anything from me,
it doesn't need anything from anybody,
it's naturally gonna progress
into one of the biggest
industries in the world.
- [Interviewer] Where do
you see it in five years?
- An accelerated version
of this where a lot
of pretenders will be
wiped out, the economy will
probably collapse in that
five years so I think
some of the hyper, over
valuation will correct itself
but it itself will continue to grow,
no different than Amazon
continuing to grow
2001 and two even though
the internet bubble bursted.
- [Interviewer] What do
you want to tell your nine
year old self right now?
- My nine year old self?
You fucking did it.
How are you, man?
(light music)
I don't know, man, fucking cool.
- It's fucking real.
- And what's crazy about it is like,
it's like all meant to
because I'll be doing this,
I've been doing this fucking flip shit,
I've been fucking working 15 hour days,
every day, five days a
week, I don't call in
but I do have one thing everyday for this
my education for the flip game
and it's all thanks to you,
I appreciate it, man.
I really...
- I'm so happy, brother.
What's been flipping well?
- Shoes been flipping well,
toys, online arbatrage,
is really my thing right.
- By on Ebay, sell on Amazon.
- Correct, correct, yeah.
- I believe in that shit a lot.
- Right, right, that's huge.
That's been huge for me.
- And this is the season, right?
- Right, yeah, Q4, Q4, absolutely.
- How long you been doing it?
- I've been doing it
for about three months,
three months and.
- It's like way more
effective than you could've
ever dreamed, right?
- It's crazy.
- Like people don't,
like literally I believe
people can make a hundred
thousand dollars a year
just going to Target and
Wal Mart, buying something,
coming home and posting it on Amazon.
- It's amazing.
- It's crazy.
- And just had to take a
little bit of convincing
from my family they should
see the proof in the pudding
and I'm doing it and it's like.
- Convincing as in like
the cynicism or like
as in like everybody throw
in five thousand bucks.
- I have a pretty good job.
- Right.
- A pretty good job and but I wanted
to be my own boss, right?
- I get it.
- You know, so, convincing my family.
- That you're not crazy.
- That yeah, exactly.
Proof is in the, you know what I mean.
- Yeah that to me is like,
the reason that I'm jumping
on that same is like the amount of people
that don't do what they wanna do because
convincing like to me
the reason I asked you
like convincing your family as in like,
you're asking them for money.
- No.
- Right so to me it goes
to the part that I'm like,
why, like how many people out there aren't
as strong as you and
never do anything 'cause
the judgment of their family
stops them from doing shit.
(murmuring)
- It's all about action, taking action.
Super simple.
- Every single thing
I've ever done in my life
people thought was
stupid until they didn't.
- Beautiful.
- Well 'cause when you do something early,
or that isn't mainstream yet, it's always
gonna be met with cynicism.
The internet was a fad when I started.
The whole thing.
The whole fucking internet.
Not flipping, not Instagram,
the whole fucking framework
was gonna be gone by the year 2000,
all these people told me.
Y2K is gonna kill the internet.
This is some of the shit that I heard
from like people that didn't know.
It's good man, I'm really happy you won.
(light music)
(cheering)
- I'm curious 'cause I'm
probably both of you guys'
biggest fans and I like
once you've made it,
what continues to drive
you to do what it is
that you're passionate about?
- You know for me it's
I felt like I made it
the way you're asking
the question when I made
a hundred thousand dollars
a year, that was like.
There's, I had never
done anything financial
and a lot of good things
have happened to me
that has remotely hit my
radar more than the year
I made a hundred thousand a year.
I would argue that if you
really knew everything about me,
and you read it all,
every action I ever did,
you would look me in the face and ask me,
why do you sabotage yourself in business
and financial environments?
And I would tell you that
deep down, subconsciously,
I love it so much that I just
want it to happen forever
and so for me making it is a you know,
that's what blows me away
about somebody whose like
well I just need to make a million bucks
and I'm gonna go to
Jamaica, right, or like,
I don't have that.
I don't have that in my head.
I just wanna play forever
and that's why I'm trying
to get people to understand the process
because it is very clear to me that people
that are in love with
their craft and process
can win and that's why
I'm trying to change
the conversation around
how much money you need
to be happy because it doesn't work
like I just know
unbelievable amounts of data
of how many people have lots of money,
how many people don't have lots of money
by our standards and how happy they are
and it doesn't take a lot of money to be
you know, to be alive in society.
It's about what you spend money on.
I mean, I can't get over
this, I just really wished
people liked what they did.
'Cause the game's very simple.
If you got debt or have to
put a roof over your head
or somebody else, then
you work, whatever job
is paying you that but I'm asking you what
are you doing from six pm to midnight
and if you have to go build
slowly your portfolio,
your Shopify store,
your Instagram account,
your YouTube channel, your content,
like wouldn't you be pumped if I told you
for the next four years it's tough
and you don't watch as much Netflix
and sports and hanging
out but then you get
to live happy for the rest of your life,
everybody in theory
would sign up for that.
The reality is a lot of
people don't wanna grind
for four years like
people don't like pain,
it's why most people don't have six packs.
I mean that, I mean that.
There's a lot of people here
who wanna be in better shape,
you just don't wanna work
out, you just don't wanna
eat well, like I lived
it for the first 38 years
of my life and then I
got into better shape.
I still hate it.
I fucking was pissed
this morning waking up
at 5:55 to workout but because I want it
and so I've gone through
doing something that didn't
come natural to me,
that I hate to this day,
four and a half years later but I just
wanna live 15 years longer
and so for me it's like
if any person here is
unhappy, I need to know
every single minute you
spend on anything but
your job because I'll tell
you, taking those leisure
hours, which you're using
to escape your unhappiness,
you're literally watching
Netflix or sports or video games
or listening to music
to escape your reality
that you're not happy about.
I want you to take those
hours and start building
something that gets you off your issue
and it might take seven
years but it's worth it.
Everybody here's gonna live for fucking
60, 70 more years.
People got tricked, 54 is young.
54 is young and so people have terrible
ability to put time in perspective,
which is why their
behaviors are so broken.
- Alright.
(laughing)
Anybody got a six pack out there?
- Show me, show me, show me.
- Alright a six pack, let's see it.
- Let's go, let's go.
My God.
That was more like 10.
- One person with a six pack.
(laughing)
- Pretty sexy out there.
- What's the power of building
relationships for you?
What does that mean?
51, 49, what does that mean for you?
- It means the only thing
that has long term value
is actual relationships,
that is the currency.
- Right.
- That's how life works.
- A hundred percent.
- Hundred percent.
(lively music)
- I run a travel website
and I study abroad soon,
I just graduated college,
I travel all the time
internationally while I was in school,
I settled down working in finance well
I don't get the chance
to travel and create
that content anymore right
now, what do I do, man,
I'm stuck, I can't.
- You can absolutely create
a framework of freelancers
who live in those spots,
who can create that content.
Every single person's a
fucking counter producer.
- Fuck yeah, dude, thanks.
(lively music)